tratemos de resolver una ecuación más
elaborada digamos la ecuación vamos a
complicar la un poco
2 x + 3 2 x 3 igual a 5 x 5 x
- 2 esto parece desalentador
tenemos x a ambos lados números que se
suman y restan a ambos lados como le
hacemos para resolver esto lo vamos a
hacer de dos maneras distintas pero lo
importante lo que tienes que tener en
mente es que se trata de despejar la x
una vez que llevas la ecuación a x igual
a algo ya resuelto para x y puedes
sustituir en la ecuación original para
verificar tu solución lo que vamos a
hacer son una serie de operaciones a
ambos lados de la ecuación para
eventualmente despejar la x a medida que
vayamos haciéndolo vamos a visualizar
que lo que está sucediendo para que no
te preocupes de cuáles son los pasos son
las reglas para resolver ecuaciones y
entonces pienses que te faltó algo que
es lo que se puede o que lo que no se
puede hacer sino que te des cuenta que
es simplemente sentido común entonces
vamos a visualizar que lo que está
sucediendo aquí tenemos 2 x es decir x +
x a lo cual le estamos sumando 3
es decir más uno más uno más uno eso
sería más tres puede ponerlo con bolitas
o como fuera
voy a indicarlo con el mismo color 2 x 3
y esto es igual a 5 x 5 x que tenemos
aquí es x mas x + x mas x + x y que
quede claro no tenemos que hacer siempre
esto para resolver ecuaciones tenemos
que trabajar algebraica mente esta
ecuación lo que estoy haciendo aquí
simplemente visualizar para que
entendamos que lo que está sucediendo el
lado izquierdo es estas dos x naranja +
3 y el lado derecho es 5 x menos 2 y
menos 2 lo podemos escribir lo podemos
escribir luego hacer en un color
distinto lo va a hacer en rosa menos 2
que podemos escribir como menos 1 - 1
ahora queremos llevar las x a un solo
lado de la ecuación como puedo hacer
esto hay dos maneras de hacer esto
podemos restar estas dos x a ambos lados
de la ecuación y así el lado derecho
obtendríamos 5 x menos 2 x un número
positivo de x
podríamos restar 5 x a ambos lados de la
ecuación es lo maravilloso del álgebra
mientras hagas operaciones válidas
siempre vas a obtener la misma respuesta
empecemos entonces restando 2 x a ambos
lados de la ecuación y qué quiere decir
restar 2x pues vamos a eliminar 2x del
lado izquierdo y para que no se altere
nuestra ecuación necesitamos eliminar 2x
del lado derecho que nos resulta de esto
estamos restando 2x del lado izquierdo y
también estamos restando 2x del lado
derecho que nos queda entonces del lado
derecho tenemos 2 x + 3 - 2 x las 2 x se
cancelan y nos queda tan solo 3 aquí lo
podemos ver eliminamos 2x y nos quedan
11 + 1 del lado derecho teníamos 5 x y
le restamos 2 x aquí lo vemos restamos 2
x a 5x y nos quedan 3 x nos quedan 3 x
- 2 no lo hicimos nada estos menos 2 nos
queda entonces del lado derecho 3 x
menos 2
usualmente para resolver ecuaciones sólo
hacemos esto que está escrito del lado
izquierdo que hacemos ahora recuerda que
queremos despejar la x ya llevamos las x
del lado derecho así es que si nos
deshacemos de este menos 2 que tenemos
aquí estaremos un paso de lograrlo
entonces cómo podemos deshacernos de
este menos 2 si lo vemos aquí es menos
uno menos uno bien podemos sumar dos a
ambos lados de la ecuación observa lo
que pasa voy a agregar dos del lado
derecho luego agregar como más uno más
uno literalmente he agregado dos y lo va
a hacer también del lado izquierdo uno
más uno más he agregado dos a ambos
lados vamos a hacerlo aquí también
sumamos dos del lado izquierdo y sumamos
dos del lado derecho que tenemos del
lado izquierdo
tenemos que tres más dos es igual a
cinco y del lado derecho
nos queda 3x menos dos más dos menos dos
más dos se cancela y nos quedan tan sólo
tres x
vamos a ver qué pasó aquí aquí tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho 123 x y menos 1 - 1 11 se
cancelan son estos términos menos dos y
más dos
la ecuación ha quedado 5 igual a 3 x
aquí lo tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 es igual a 3 x
deja de borrar lo que ya hemos eliminado
de aquí estas 2 x ya están eliminadas
aquí también
esto de aquí ya lo hemos eliminado de la
ecuación y esto de aquí vamos a borrar
perfecto ya lo tenemos así es que esto
nos ha quedado 1 2 3 4 5 deja de mover
esto deja de pegarlo vamos a cortar
y pegarse muy bien aquí tenemos 5 estos
dos son estos dos que sumamos aquí que
es igual a 3x estos 12 se cancelaron ya
no aparecen ahí ahora para resolver esto
simplemente dividimos ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 3 y esto va a ser un poco
difícil de visualizar pero si dividimos
aquí entre 3 que obtenemos dividimos
entre 3 del lado izquierdo y dividimos
entre 3 del lado derecho y la razón por
la cual dividimos entre 3 es porque la
equis está multiplicada por 3 3 es el
coeficiente de x esa palabra extraña que
significa el número que multiplica a una
variable estos tres se cancelan así es
que el lado derecho nos queda la equis y
del lado izquierdo cinco tercios cinco
tercios hemos encontrado que x es igual
a cinco tercios y esto es diferente a lo
que habíamos visto hasta ahora la equis
está del lado derecho el cinco tercios
está del lado izquierdo pero la solución
sigue siendo x igual a cinco tercios es
lo mismo escribir cinco tercios igual a
equis que escribir x
igual a cinco tercios estamos más
acostumbrados a esta pero son totalmente
equivalentes esta de aquí es exactamente
lo mismo si queremos escribir la
solución como número mixto bueno 53 es
igual a 1 y sobran 2 es decir x es igual
a un entero dos tercios va a ser un
entero dos tercios la solución también
lo podemos escribir como x igual a un
entero dos tercios y te dejo de tarea
que sustituyese el valor de x en la
ecuación original y ver que
efectivamente es correcto ahora
regresando a nuestra visualización cómo
le hacemos para ver un entero dos
tercios veamos esto en vez de usar unos
voy a usar círculos voy a usar círculos
no pensándolo bien voy a usar cuadrados
voy a tener tres cuadrados del lado
izquierdo los voy a hacer en amarillo
4 y 5 y eso es igual a
3 x x mas x mas x ahora estamos
dividiendo a ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 3 estamos dividiendo ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 3 eso fue lo que
hicimos aquí dividir ambos lados entre 3
y eso como lo vemos aquí bueno el lado
derecho es muy fácil que es divide estas
3 x en tres grupos uno dos tres tres
grupos ahora como podemos visualizar 53
tenemos que formar grupos iguales y la
respuesta nos da la pista cada grupo va
a tener un entero y dos tercios entonces
aquí tenemos un grupo de un entero dos
tercios tomamos dos tercios del
siguiente nos queda un tercio aquí nos
queda aquí un tercio le agregamos el
siguiente cuadro completamente llevamos
un entero un tercio hay que agregarle un
tercio más del siguiente ya tenemos un
entero dos tercios y ya quedaron los
tres grupos de un entero dos tercios
aclaremos la visualización aquí tenemos
un grupo este es un entero y aquí
tenemos dos tercios así es que aquí hay
un entero dos tercios luego aquí tenemos
un tercio aquí tenemos otro tercio y
aquí tenemos un entero aquí tenemos otro
grupo de un entero dos tres
y finalmente aquí tenemos dos tercios y
aquí tenemos un entero el último grupo
de un entero dos tercios así es que
cuando dividimos ambos lados entre tres
del lado izquierdo obtenemos tres
secciones o tres paquetes de un entero
dos tercios equivalentes a cinco tercios
que estamos obteniendo el lado izquierdo
del lado derecho nos queda x y aunque es
más difícil la visualización con
fracciones también funciona